we had sensual makeout session they
burnt it down with our fire we had
questionable musical performances thank
you thank you and we had a hot tub this
is your bachelorette Episode six recap
grab your glasses it's time for roses
and Rosie hi you guys i'm lauren zima
what an episode oh let's just take a big
drink for being back on track everybody
we have the reset Hannah wanted we
stayed in our lane if you guys have ever
driven a car it's worth whatever Drive
all over the road so much to talk about
you guys and I want to promise you we're
gonna talk about the Jed's stuff so
buckle it up stay in your lane drive
your car don't talk on your phone let's
go
did you like the episode overall do you
feel back on track let me know
so we have left the mansion because
remember that's where we were at the end
of that last weird 5b episode and we're
back in Riga and remember we love Latvia
and the guys are brewing out in Latvia
they love your bucket love Rio why are
you saying this okay can't trust our
love love Hanna and Garrett gets the
one-on-one and Garrett is so nice to
meet you we're excited to get to know
you
what's your deal ask naked so Garrett
and Hannah's one on one is gonna be
naked bungee jumping and I love how this
was sold as a tradition of latvia
contribution here lots people ruffles to
do that I googled it I could find
nothing about the centuries-long
practice of naked bungee jumping in the
culture of Latvia
a cornerstone to the local tradition and
custom oh man in Latvia you do it the
Latvia way somebody tell me if I'm wrong
I don't know are there any Latvians in
the house but drink for them selling
this date as a cultural moment that
needed to be adds great a lot of peril
on this date right it's very cold and
there bungee jumping and they're naked
and then it starts raining oh my god
like what else can happen here I've
never been bungee jumping but I just
feel you know you get like whiplashed
around and I just kept thinking about
like all of their floppy your body parts
okay I'm like like ah I would just want
to hold it looks dangerous and painful
and hannah is like clinging to Garrett
and Garrett's like I got you you can
trust me trust me
and I would say Garrett Garrett Garrett
Garrett no offense to you I don't mean
to trust you I need to trust the dude
hooking my naked butt up in the harness
as a jump and freefall through the sky
down above a brown muddy river possibly
to my death or it's a very least my
disgust at the dinner we get to know
about Garrett and like his football
family and great I appreciate getting to
know people more about your stories it's
a show about stories of journeys and
here we are and then Garrett talks about
the date again funny the way it is you
think about it you know he's like you
know Hanna today was a metaphor symbolic
in a way for falling in love it is a lot
like falling in love
Wow I mean this is some Ralph Waldo
Emerson Walt Whitman Maya Angelou stuff
Garrett so then Garrett continues with
his falling and he says I'm falling in
love for you laying the cards on the
table I'm falling in love for you I
don't know if that's ever been said on
the show I'm falling in love for you
here
will you accept this ring yes ma'am
so the date goes well Garrett gets a
rose and then Garrett and Hanna are
dancing in the street and I just want to
take a moment for Hanna's outfit because
what is she wearing
she looks like a villainous Elle Woods
from Legally Blonde it's like this faux
furry pink coat but then things like
studded gloves I did it it was Elle
Woods meets karela deville and they
exploded together in laughter maybe
that's a tradition of Latvia studded
bedazzled gloves with colorful faux fur
naked jumping let me know what you
thought of her outfit in the comments
below then we're back in the house and
Garrett comes in and he is really
walking the guys step by step through
how he fell naked with Hannah didn't you
think he was like yeah her head was
right here I was hugging her and she was
hugging me and she put her shoulder her
head right here and she's naked and I'm
like jeez like it felt forced didn't it
it felt like the producers encouraged
Garrett to say that and I don't have a
problem with it because it makes for a
great show anyway you know what drink
for every first time it's ever happened
it's never happened in three years
my shoe it's covered in Rosie I'm so
sorry
oh sorry everyone I spilled Rosie I've
never committed such a sin
this is some Shakespeare stuff right
here oh say oh I felt like dropping a
baby yeah I said that I'm hearing good
story and I don't I don't know if that's
how it went down obviously Garrett's
story upsets Luke and Luke made a weird
comment though he it's his responses who
would want to be naked with that guy who
would want to be naked with that guy
that's like actually probably some
people don't care it's a good-looking
guy anyway now we're on to the group
date and it's a market date oh we love
our market dates we're exploring the
town we're getting a touch of the local
customs it's a market date and Hanna is
like shopping for fruits and veggies I
don't know why she's not gonna eating
those she's placed in a hotel she looks
cute we love a drop earring this season
you know drink every time we see a drop
earring some of these look terrifying
I'm gonna eat them as a reminder to
everyone and I tweeted out this PSA
Dustin and Dylan are still contestants
of a season of The Bachelorette and I'm
not sure we have ever heard Dustin speak
let's just toast to a great day but he
speaks drink every time he speaks mm-hm
this might be why we haven't heard him
speak he says let's toast to a great day
and moonshine is no Hemingway you know
and then we get another shot of Dustin
eating a fish head this is rough it's
rough for Dustin hmm so they're at the
market and Tyler decides because he's
Tyler to get Hannah some flowers excuse
me fellas and oh my God look at Jed's
face through this shot as Tyler girls
here are the flowers Jed is jealous and
you guys we need to talk about Jack I
gave a very quick reaction to breaking
news at the end of last week's roses and
Rosie this report that Jed had dated a
woman up until the night before he went
on the show and allegedly told her that
he would date her when he came back home
that he was just going on the show for
his career I have a lot of issues with
this I don't think you should go on a
dating show when you're dating someone
else I will just say that we've heard
this woman's side of the story so before
I give my full opinion on it I'm getting
here Jed's it's a mess
oh so beautiful
I need you to give me a chance to be
there for you but you know now
everything that Jed says is really cast
with a problematic light isn't it we're
seeing it through a different lens like
when Jed says to Hanna on the state I
want to be your rock when you're off
it's like yes
do you now we have questions drink every
time we have a yikes moment mmm
Dylan this year I think Dylan hasn't
spoken is Dylan a ghost
it's still unreal are we all seeing
Dylan I want everybody you know you
probably watch The Bachelorette with
your friend I want you to turn to a
friend when you see Dylan and say do you
see him do you see what I see I see a
ghost
is everybody seeing him Dylan drink
every time you see Dylan
mm-hmm-hmm please drink responsibly
getting a lot of drinking games going
this episode anyway Stacey will come out
and I'm like
Hannah then tells the guys about naked
bungee jumping with Garrett then her
body is her temple and to expose it to
anyone who isn't her husband that was a
slap in my face I just want to remind
you Luke of the facts and the facts are
that you took your shirt off to make out
with Hannah on like night too so why is
that okay yeah on Luke then the
after-party and oh my god Tyler Tyler
thank you for being here thank you for
being you
oh my god if Tyler doesn't end up with
Hannah is he here pick for bachelor I
don't know in the comments below
Tyler talks to Hannah and says that she
is just an angel and Wyatt knew wearing
all white and that he loves her strong
side and that he hopes she can be his
angel like a pretty guy that you're my
angel you know
Tyler we're already
okay and jets playing Hannah's song
drink every time we have a musical
performance in this episode hmm as a
reminder Jed did tell Hannah straight up
I went on the show for my musical career
and I guess he's really leaning into
that still I'm just happy today went
well hopefully tonight goes even better
ghosts Dylan is here because it's his
turn to wear the salmon blazer honestly
like I'm just thinking of you holding
him bare skin and I'm just thinking in
my mind like it really pissed me off
he is obviously jealous no matter what
you do I'm going to support you says
without saying that Hannah made a
boneheaded move by doing the naked
bungee jumping with Garrett if you make
a boneheaded mistake and you just do
something completely of your character
at the end of the day no matter what
like we're gonna get to be anything and
she is looking at him like what the are
you saying we were all thinking it
Hannah you're a good dude Peter you
deserve this let's bask in the sunshine
let's sing from the treetops let's fly
through
pilot Pete gets the one-on-one everybody
oh my gosh you guys the joy this brought
me Peter is smiling and all is right in
the world they're doing a spa day all
right
great Hannah and Peter they go to
something called pertz yes it's here yes
again these latvian traditions it's
intimate place where you can open your
heart it's described as a magical place
we can find yourself and get close with
your partner and then turns out it's a
sauna this usually we say selling them
you can find it at your college gym at
an equinox at a YMCA probably so they're
making some concoctions and you know we
get another musical performance mm oh
god I think one of the words in that
woman's song was literally spa god I
wish we had a translator on it and then
they are taking their ropes off and they
are getting sexy and things are about to
get exciting in the sauna and I'm ready
to see this makeout scene we've been
teased too in the trailer and then those
people are still there
[Applause]
it's like wizard and we are in the sauna
with them in hats aren't they sweating
just beating them with leaves it's like
get out get out we're ready for the make
out I need you to get out
they finally leave and Peter pulls what
has become his signature move which is
to like sexily but awkwardly so adorably
push Hanna down just like on the pool
table but now it's a hot sauna bench for
a makeout sesh let's drink for this
makeout sesh I mean it's just like says
sexually driven like so hot were you
guys surprised by how expository Hanna
was about the sexual chemistry with
Peter she was like we have so much
chemistry it's a ten out of ten our
physical connection is a 10 out of 10
we'd seen her say that in the trailers
and I thought she was talking about Luke
I did not see the sexy side of Peter I'm
blown away the super sexy Peter where
did he come from
Pilate Pete pretty sexy piece and then
this show is the gift that keeps on
giving everybody we are finally on track
everybody we are in our lane the show is
moving
it's our first hot tub of this season
I found but I wanted that celebrate so
exciting you guys it is outdoors we have
champagne and of course brought to us by
pilot Pete this is so creaky this couch
so there in the hot tub drink every time
they say fire like that fire you burnt
it down with our fire
drink every time they say hot and
hottest yeah I just think it better now
so hot so hot in every sense drink every
time they make out don't do that dinner
with Peter I don't know where we are a
restaurant I cave no matter what the
show makes the show look like the show
doesn't it like there's candles and it's
sexy and just props to the set design
okay great
I kind of draw my strength a lot from
honestly what I do for work I like what
Peter said about drawing strength from
his job as a pilot from the pressure of
that this is a real conversation this is
a connection this is what we need and
then wait wait wait my mom would always
tell me the same you guys like me no not
that is Ferris Bueller speaks española
sighs go ahead
oh my god Peter just throws out this
full sentence in Spanish there must be a
side of the family we're not aware of
yet cuz this last name is Webber oh my
god Peter what can't you do
and Betty for the Spanish anyway what do
you guys think of Peter and Hanna state
it was great I just wonder how they know
when a dates over
obviously Peter gets a roast or the
producers come in and they're like and
you got to give it Rose man I only have
10 more minutes left for filming partner
here okay
I'm just wondering I'm gonna try to find
out so good okay Peter comes back to the
guys and then Jed pulls a move
Jed decides he wants to go see Hannah
and he does and I don't want to shock
you but he sings to her and then they're
lying down in bed okay but let's talk
about some of Jed's lyrics and drink for
all the Ike's moments Jed says quote
I would never tell them lie big promise
to make uh many talks in his song about
is it a sin to be scared just kid I
don't know ask father Luke and they're
making out and jed's like can I tell you
something and I'm like is he gonna tell
her about the girlfriend thing and then
he doesn't he tells her these falling oh
god just like got himself a full
one-on-one Congrats to Jed I was told by
multiple members of the group that you
brought up our one-on-one date then
Garrett and Luke are back in their war
of words and Luke says that he wants to
quote tuck it under the rug I wanted to
tuck him the rug Luke in his freezing I
think he meant brush it under the rug
but he said tuck it tuck it on the rug
okay and then you know Hanna had told
the guys to stay in their Lane stay in
your freaky Lane and they're really
taking this to heart and Luke is really
taking this metaphor to heart I'm not
getting in your lane but when I'm
driving in my lane I look over and I see
Hanna with you and he's like literally
pantomiming like we are in a full game
of charades now he's like here you need
to say I never win your lane and you
know I might look over and see you and
then but I'm trying to say my Lane ever
he's like what if you swerve and it's
just like you know what it's like
Garrett I might like roll the window
down to talk to you but then I might
like roll it back up but I'm not sure if
my car's electric or an old-school
manual and like I don't know I might
have my hands at Tennant to but that I
might be getting a call and then I might
hold it like this because in my state
it's illegal to be on the phone while
driving you have to be hands-free so
maybe I should hook up my Bluetooth and
then you know I might want to turn on
the radio and hear a love song and I
don't know do I have serious or did my
free subscription that came with my car
expire already I'm turning left are you
turning right are we at a stoplight now
that's you coming in Miley I have
questions
okay Oh God
we are speeding down the highway towards
an inevitable crash with Luke though
aren't we yeah we see him stay in his
Lane and go away in that car all right I
just wanna make sure this right now is
not brought out to throw ceremony why is
it why is it your business what Hanna
and I talked about tomorrow's rose
ceremony Luke does not want this
discussion to go into the rose ceremony
and it's like Luke you wanted to talk to
Han about Garrett so you can't say stuff
like that and then Garrett says sweet
dreams Luke the door is right there
sweet dreams Luke that's like sweet
Jesus scared when did you get so scary
but bungee-jump really empowered you
made you fearless
so all the guys are hanging out and I
don't see Dylan he may have gone home
it's unclear mmm maybe he's there but
he's in his translucent ghost form
Hanna comes in and grabs Luke like can I
talk deeper stuff and it sort of made me
sad to see how excited Luke was like it
popped right up but we know this
conversation is gonna be bad Dustin
speaks drink for Dustin mmm so Hannah
gets Luke and confronts him thank God
about that boneheaded mistake comment it
was not cool and obviously been
bothering her you said we all make
boneheaded mistakes and I got I'll give
Luke some credit he's staying quiet then
he's asking if he can speak
start getting into yeah and then he's
saying some good things now I never
wants to control Hanna
but then Luke does what he always does
and he keeps talking and he starts to
say things that are not okay and Hanna
says why is this so hard why is it so
hard with us Hanna it's been this hard
you guys are not on the same wavelength
I don't know why you're fighting for
this so vigorously but let it go hey
guys it's me I had to vlog because I
just thought I had to see a little more
about the Luke and Hanna stuff here's
the thing Hanna confronted Luke about
what he said to her about how
condescending he was to her about her
ability to make her own decisions and I
applaud Hanna for that and then Luke
very frustratingly backtracked on what
said and ultimately asked Hanna to fight
for him but the thing is what are they
fighting for I said you're not staying
in your own lane and he said yes I am
I'm driving my truck my own lane my job
the guys are all back together and this
metaphor is continuing Luke even says
don't text and drive that's how you
crash
yeah don't text and drive Chris comes in
and says is this everybody I'm not sure
is doing here
there's no cocktail party if you guys
will get dressed
we'll see you rose ceremony the guys are
gonna blame Luke for that
I'm not really sure that's fair what did
you guys think fair to blame Luke I
actually don't think so I think Hanna
knows that Dustin and Dylan are not the
ones for here in fact I'm not even sure
that they're real anyway
he does have some tough decisions to
make Connor speaks and I'm just so glad
to like have heard Connor speak for like
one time this episode because I love
Connors voice Luke he is successfully
taken away Hanna's opportunities to
fully get to know everyone here Dylan
speaks
Dylan is real Dylan Dylan says he hasn't
talked to Hannah I haven't talked to
Hannah for three Conoco fairies about
tracks and we got another cool car
moment with Hannah was the car in its
lane I don't know which side of the road
of people drive on in Latvia what kind
of car is this does it have automatic
shifting we know Luke's gonna get the
road cuz we've seen him in the teaser
they still have to have that whole
confrontation I was my god I cannot
believe you just said that I'm so mad
goodbye Dustin and Dylan find that
fellow right that felt in our lane and
Jed says Luke isn't real with Hanna
you're just not real I just never feel
like it's ever been real Wow another
yikes moment from Jeff who's being real
here Dredd I got a question and Hannah
tells Chris that she's either Paola
making me go crazy I'm not sure Victoria
driving or crazy down the highway
towards a bridge that isn't finished and
that bridge is going into troubled water
next week on The Bachelorette then we
get the trailer and we have Tyler on a
horse and Garrett saying I love you and
Peter and Luke fighting you gave me your
word don't you fight with bear and okay
you guys I never talk about those final
moments that come during the credits but
oh my god Tyler dancing is everything
Tyler is dancing like Elvis and he is in
the tightest whitest pants in the world
his even lying pants this title season
if I've been missing this that's all I
have to say who is your pick for Hannah
who's your pick for bachelor I love you
guys so much I am on cameo if you want
to get a cameo you can get it there and
I'll sing a cool song for you thank you
so much for watching and being here I
love you
[Music]
by the way she usually calls me in at
this time so the cameras were still
rolling so hi everybody
[Music]